is by myself okay
so I'm good here I push like that until
my hand can't stay up and then I push
you also feel that in your paper usually
it gets over round okay so my arm is
going to do a spiral skin to go elbow
Yong had head and is going to go past
the midpoint
the other side has young fellow yet do
you see that okay
[Music]
elbow starts my shoulder line hand
starts halfway remember dawn line get in
line at Centerpoint
two down the boy then again young but it
just do the shape forget about him on
your hands
make sure the elbow gets to that other
my elbow is that the young line in this
drill don't go oh he go or don't don't
do that stay with what we're doing so
when I go like that I put the hand too
young the elbow is out of play it's now
week okay so that's not what we do this
drill this elbow is young and this is
going to end up yeah that's this drill
there's no nothing there
serve relaxing I have to if I do this
correctly the elbow that was on the
bottom ends up on the top you see not
down below elbows on the bottom both
elbow on top bottom and I'm just relaxed
because I'm not pushing on him
I just rotating this elbow
[Music]
don't change the angle no no no it keeps
angle goes no keeps the angle I rewind
it keeps the angle you see don't go in
and out keeps the angle boom keep stag
keeps the distance does not come in so
they don't hinge there keeps the
distance ohms gone
rewind Oh keeps the distance okay don't
change the rotation
no the whole thing moves won't hear no
wrong whole thing rotates
no elbow didn't rotate elbow changed
angle shoulder changed angle okay
pay attention Barty boos body body moves
one this drill nothing moves just a part
this drill nothing moves body mousse
body moves
not see that difference
body moves elbows outside the original
shoulder line here I'm gonna put my body
back inside
[Music]
Hey look
we move emos
if I let steam out
you see double up he stays he moves his
Center his Center my Center his center
why Santa his center that's why I taking
his center put it on mine in attorney
month okay doc he's out there and I do
like that your elbow Bend and the
shoulder angle they change because
you're pushing with those joints and
then they get heavy and get compromised
so I though I'm not pushing with your
joint good it's the same drill I'm doing
the same girl and I just moved
let's say around here is where you guys
want to push with your hat in it gets
compromised you see he pushes and he
gets like leave it in place this pushes
so you go and you want the ball the
other way so you push with the elbow and
the elbow bends cause he's heavier than
you you want to go the other way bring
this back then you want to keep going
don't push here push with your Center
nobody's here he's here and I'm doing
this technique no I'm not
nothing changes feeling he's here don't
do that extra
we see his time sliding up can you see
that because he's not has the opposite
problem okay
he's pushing on me now I'm too strong we
can't can't keep his grip Hey
[Music]
okay try it
you'll get this I know it already so I'm
not swear anymore
I have an angle so this this angle is
accented by doc you see I'll still do it
[Music]
all still do it
I'll still do it hold in hey let's get
something good and I'm already written
might change the angle easy or I change
angle here don't stay in front the
attendant run backward move things can
be seized in front okay this has to do
it don't go here and go like that so
what's in here
whoa there yes this is without wool I
feel this pressure by releasing see not
here push my Friday pressure
hold this time mr. back yet it doesn't
matter
boom move so pay attention here move
oh not here here oh I I am not moving
out of the way and I'm not pulling them
stay there stay there stay there stay
there stay there you see how I'm doing
that
now I have a decision hey just enough
pressure and the pressure doesn't go I'm
not going out here I stay on the
pressure oh I feel the pressures
starting to come off if I went too far
keep the pressure keep the pressure
that's telling me when to turn it so if
I'm going like this and I go like this
you're not going to be able to do the
drill you're throwing a guy on you and
then you're thrown about that's not like
you
so even though these grippy I'm not
pulling this grip inside this room I can
teach it inside his wrist
inside this trip all too much just is
not here is brunch
he tilted he think by his stead remember
about projector so I'm not going like
this and then he's following my arm his
center moves Bowl to get that difference
you broke the other rules one of these
strong
[Music]
stop saying this this body which way is
it going this this was in the way you
think it starts to turn which way is my
hand going towards me away from me look
at it again measure its Kemp came
towards me do you think so he's going in
that's the hit move of the technique but
you guys use it do you see it makes no
sense because your arms get it short
okay but the elbow started on the bottom
and it has the young you see it started
here and it ends up here so the lift is
on my down not on my up okay so he's
coming
and fall is when he gets lifted my elbow
does it not my half not my hat the
happenings who did
oh-ho does it elbow dressing boom okay
let's go
[Applause]
Tammy watches Anna
Tammy it moves right into it so it's not
here right into it
[Music]
pasta and then one two three has to be
in the area not only this is not
Marshall big mine won't need one
then elbow midline all again yawns whoa
this meetings to the transition so it
should be in the transition space you
get it mom
and this time is gonna go to the young
space full transition through so no
leave it here okay don't reach it back
here and then don't be after either this
hit my back this hip tip over
attend me you see this hip went forward
right and this hips go BA not here
all the sound this hip you see do you
guys see this hit boom boom which
happens when you throw okay then we're
going to change from the drill boom
right here
I'll cross the other Center go oh me
feel that Center I didn't push him he's
gonna go around me so his name say my
condition say my kidneys
say my kids just sit up and he's going
that way
[Music]
- alright see is Hannah's face
it's going to move this way right here
right there not here is a picture
[Music]
all right he's pushing on me he's just
waiting there I just come in
so warm your films power don't do this
don't do that keep the cycle going to
the other side of your body and I'm in
then down redirected push coming out so
when I go to here and I in turn ask
yourself does this happen stay out talk
from my body no you see he got closer to
you that's leaking absorption
this became the job so he's not like
last time Mohan he's alive he doesn't
want me to kill him you see
[Music]
get your feet under you sit the hip is
going
and I don't go around here not going
like this I'm on the I'm on the inside
I'm on the inside this way not this way
here
so watch for that I'm going to do the
two ways
[Music]
didn't I let him go because he's my
friend okay
when I got this pop not this pop this
pod and I'd look I let it out
[Music]
come on y'all